STEPHANIE WONG: As
a Cloud Developer,
one realization
you quickly have is
that despite being
on the cloud, you
don't want everything
publicly accessible.
In this episode of
Cloud Networking,
we cover how to protect
your internal endpoints
using Cloud NAT.
Stay tuned.
Let's say you've got
a cloud application
with internal
services and you want
to restrict inbound
communication while still
allowing outbound.
One of the traditional
ways to do this
would be through a VPN service
that secures, authorizes,
and handles that connection
for you, which is fine but runs
into a large problem
that you're still
using public IPs,
which leaves you
vulnerable to malicious actors.
Another secure setup
would be something
called a bastion host--
basically an external endpoint
which allows your clients
to SSH from the public
internet and still
keep your apps from being
public-facing, which,
again, works, but this
only deals with one
side of the problem.
Namely, inbound communication.
But let's say you have a
multi-tiered application
setup in the cloud and you have
an update server on premise.
You want to allow your
instances outbound access
to the internet for
updates, patching,
config management, and more
without having an external IP
address.
That way, you can
keep your instances
entirely internet-facing in
a controlled and efficient
manner.
For this, it makes
a lot more sense
to setup a Network
Address Translation, NAT,
gateway machine, which routes
traffic and lets multiple VMs
in a subnet reach the internet
using a single public IP
address.
Now, normally, this
requires a fair bit of toil.
Building a high availability
and high bandwidth NAT gateway
usually requires reserving
static IP addresses,
creating compute instance
groups as the NAT gateways,
creating health checks to
monitor their responsiveness,
and adding default routes
to these instances.
And with traditional NATs,
you'd have a NAT proxy
instance between
your cloud instances
and their destination.
This means a potential
choke point in the path,
undermining performance,
throughput, and availability.
Fortunately, Google Cloud NAT
is a software-defined networking
SDN solution that
avoids these problems.
It's a fully managed offering
that lets Google Cloud VM
instances without
external IP addresses
and private GKE clusters
connect to the internet.
It doesn't require custom
routing and simplifies
and delivers scale,
because it uses
SDN instead of being an
instance or an appliance
that you have to manage.
And better yet,
outside resources
can't directly access any of the
private instances behind Cloud
NAT, thereby helping to keep
your VPCs isolated and secure.
The best part?
It doesn't use a proxy.
Instead, each of your
internal instances
is given a unique set of
NAT IPs and port ranges,
which are used by Andromeda,
Google's network virtualization
stack, to perform that.
This means no choke
points, better scalability,
performance, and availability.
Cloud NAT scales seamlessly
with the number of instances
and the volume of
network traffic.
And you get as much bandwidth
as instances that do
have external IP addresses.
Let's dive into how
to set up Cloud NAT.
Here I have two VMs set up
in the same VPC and subnet.
I want web server to be
private, so I've set it up
with no external IP address.
In order to access it,
I've set up a second VM
to act as a bastion host,
which does have an external IP
and allows for inbound
traffic to my web server.
I've also set up
firewall rules so
that I can only use the bastion
host to SSH into the web
server.
I'm using the local terminal
to SSH into the bastion host
to then SSH into the web server.
You can see here I
don't have the ability
to access the public
internet, because when
I try to pull content from
example.com, it hangs.
Now, let's set up Cloud
NAT to route egress traffic
from the web server to the
internet using Cloud NAT's
allocation of IP addresses.
Head to the Google Cloud NAT
page and click Get Started.
Enter a gateway name.
Choose the VPC network
your instances are in.
Set the region for
the NAT gateway,
which should be the same as
where your instances are.
Now create a Cloud Router in
the region and give it a name.
Leave the rest as
default. Leave the NAT IP
addresses to automatic, which
is recommended and automatically
allocates IP addresses
based on usage.
These IPs are used to translate
the internal addresses
of instances.
And now click Create.
Now, going back to my
web server instance,
I can now access example.com and
see its content while it still
has no external IP address.
It's important to note that
Cloud NAT doesn't set up
inbound NAT.
So instances outside
your VPC can't
initiate their own new
connections to your cloud
instances with NAT.
But Cloud NAT is a
great managed service
for things like fetching
periodic updates
from an external server
and another network.
As you grow your
cloud environment,
centralizing control and
simplifying your network
topology is going to save
you cycles in the long run.
Stay tuned for the next episode.
And remember,
optimizing your network
means freeing up your bandwidth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]